[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to
gamespot's coverage of summer game fest
key 3
20 20. i'm lucy james yes i know i'm
sounding a little bit more sultry than
usual uh but joining me is a phil honcho
you've been to play warhammer 40k
darktide right and i despite i used to
live with dave dewitt on our team
um
he's a big warhammer boy i've never
the only warhammer i've ever really
interacted with was when they did the
lord of the rings stuff back when the
movies first came out my knowledge of
warhammer not the strongest however dark
tied like vermintide before it seems to
be a little easier to get into yeah so
i'm also not much of a warhammer person
um and actually i had missed vermintide
as well but i am a big fan of games like
left 4 dead and of that sort of
vibe so
yeah my angle of this was like can i be
the guy who just jumps in and like can i
learn
enough about warhammer to have a good
time and yes the answer is yeah it's uh
it's mostly about smashing people with a
hammer good face
good and when you're not smashing them
with a hammer you have a gun now which
you can shoot them with so that's bolt
gun no regular that's a regular it's a
more yeah i guess more hammer guns
40k guns is a specific thing um and fans
will know um i had it explained to me i
don't remember exactly
you have notes right right
talking about just the law i imagine
there is a lot there to love for the
hardcore
um it's been written by dan abner who is
um so i've been told a very big figure
in the warhammer kind of law and writing
scene um but for you when you picked up
the game for the first time what were
your immediate impressions how did it
hook you in yeah so um i didn't play a
ton we played like one mission about 30
minutes right and it's pretty much like
a left for dead level in that you're
like running from one to end to the
other doing objectives along the way
fighting guys um the fun part for me
having no real understanding of the
world
was uh it's all banter
sneaking is no job for oakland
oh i'm sorry we'll drop you bang on a
scout fortress next time
right so you've got four players on a
team um in this game
as opposed to vermintide you're picking
a class and like customizing a character
whereas before you would have uh picked
a character who is specific and so
because of that you are filling in like
interesting elements of their character
like backstory with planet they're from
how they everybody was a prisoner before
and that's they're being like thrown
into this meat grinder because of
they were in jail it's much more about i
think picking the kind of personality
which is there are a couple options per
class
and so because you're you're defining
your personality the way you interact
with the other characters is kind of
defined that way and it creates a lot of
um
different remixes of the way those
characters will interact and because
they're you're picking a class and not a
specific character you can have
four of like the ogre the huge guy
on a team and they can all have you know
potentially different personalities or a
couple of different personalities and
how they bounce off each other changes
depending on who's in the team what
their personalities are kind of that
team makeup so yeah like you're getting
the story i think a lot of it through
the osmosis of
just hanging out and having different
combinations of prisoners going in and
hopefully not getting run over so
no i really i really like that you know
i played a bunch of back for blood and
obviously left for dead and it's like
yeah i'm just gonna pick
mom again and i'll get all of her voice
lines and everything um but you know
there has been this kind of resurgence
obviously with backflip blood last year
um so and you mentioned that you really
enjoy that kind of genre what is dark
tide doing differently or even you know
maybe improving upon previous games that
have come right well so it's um similar
to vermintide they're really leaning
into melee combat that's kind of you
know what these games are known for it's
really good here too you've got like
this i had i was playing the zealot
class which is kind of a
you you've got like a blink move that
lets you get in close and then you can
charge up your hammer with electricity
and just start wailing on people so that
all feels really really good um the
addition is uh for the series is the
ranged combat and because of that you've
got like a lot of different enemy
encounters that you might not feel like
you would have in other you know like
zombie-based
forms of this game there's a lot of
melee comment but there's also a lot of
like controlling the battlefield and
figuring out where the range threats are
and like
tuning things so that you know that
you're getting a unified front so you're
not getting
hit from the back and stuff like that um
so yeah it's a it has like a sort of
different feel uh because of that but
you also it's riffing on all of those
same ideas you know you've got like your
elite characters who come in and shoot
like a net gun at you and suddenly
you're tied up on the ground
so yeah it's it's riffing on it but it's
uh it'll feel familiar i think for
people who are into that sort of thing
so how does that last in terms of like
progression
yeah so i didn't see a ton of it yeah
but i did i did hear about it um and
it's because it's so customizable you're
like building a character and you're
gonna choose uh as you level up i think
you get three different like traits you
can unlock as you go up tiers and so you
can kind of tune how your character um
exists inside their certain class right
and so uh the other classes that we
didn't play like one of them um has like
access to magic but in warhammer if you
used to magic magic too much you blow up
because it's kind of dark right so like
how the uh how the magic works and and
you know what you can do with it and
like how often i guess you would blow
yourself up can be tuned through your
customization and then you have access
to a number of different character slots
right like you can make a bunch of
different characters with different
personalities and with different tunes
up the tree so yeah it like
it's it progresses in that way so that
you can kind of uh customize your play
style as you're going yeah i really like
that and so you were playing with three
others
and everyone is it does it feel like you
have
obviously you have the classes that you
consume but does it feel like everyone
has a specific role oh yes definitely
yeah so you like i mentioned the ogre
guy who is like
twice as big as everybody else and he's
like very clearly a tank and he has a
huge
knife and like in his hand it looks like
a butcher knife but to everyone else
it's like the size of another guy
you know and so like obviously he's kind
of tanking damage and uh my role uh as
the zealot was you're sort of getting in
fast you're trying to
recognize with your melee um abilities
and then maybe bounce out before it gets
too yeah yeah kind of like your standard
dps hunter kind of feel
um there you've got your magic users
with a little more range uh and you've
got a straight up um warhammer like
marine right who's got like the lace gun
and picking off headshots and stuff
handling the range threats so that we're
not getting uh sniped out basically
which was a whole problem so
well how did you how did you find the
balance of it um was it pretty yeah it
felt good yeah yeah um i you know like i
said i didn't play it for too long so it
was hard to get too much of a feel of it
but yeah like
the game has that sort of same uh
director ai director thing kind of like
creating the the encounters as you go
and so like the i watched a bit before i
got there a little early and got to see
how another team was handling it and
like their encounters had a lot more of
these guys who were like hitting him
with the neck guns and so they were
getting like locked up a lot more and
they couldn't they weren't doing a good
job of like catching those because those
guys like try to sneak up on you
when we ran it uh i was looking for
those guys and like we i caught a few of
them they weren't really all that
effective so they stopped popping up it
was almost you know like if it felt a
little different when we went through we
had a few more big guys come like
straight at us because we were doing a
good job of like knocking those guys out
so
yeah um and yeah you said the the level
ran for about half an hour yeah about
that and you know a lot of it was like
get to a place open a door this sort of
left for dead things that you have to do
when we got to the end we had to like
fuel up a uh a transport to get the heck
out of there and so we were defending a
whole like loading dock for a long time
carrying these big power cells over to
the um oh slowly yes exactly and you
like toss it and like fight back and so
it was a lot of working together to try
and defend each other for that and yeah
it's you know it's it seems but it seems
like it has that warhammer feel and also
it sounds like the progress through
missions is going to have a lot of
interesting variation yeah does it does
it uh make you want to get more into
warhammer so you can appreciate the
larger school yeah you know like this is
i keep having friends kind of like ping
me and i'm a lore guy anyway so like if
you if you start talking about your
story i kind of like can't help myself
um the way that you described it is that
like you can come in you don't have to
know anything you can just pick it up
and smash people with a hammer
but there are plenty of there's a story
going on in the game even though
you know it's mostly about shooting guys
and smashing guys but there's stuff
there
and there are a lot of little lore hooks
that might pull you into the uh the
larger world like it's very very aware
obviously of like the warhammer 40k
universe and so it sounds like if you're
interested you can find that stuff if
you go looking for it and it might pull
you into the rest of the world so yeah i
feel like it could be a cool on-ramp to
get into warhammer because what happened
to me feels at like at this point
this is the same opinion i have about
wrestling and final fantasy 14 where it
is so big and it is so storied and has
so much history it's difficult to find
that right thing that will just let you
get in yeah so i'm very intrigued by
that yeah this seems like chill enough
that you don't have to like know
everything or really dedicate that time
you can kind of go at your own pace and
catch into the story and then as you
like get more and more interested feels
like it feels like it might actually be
kind of dangerous if you'll like kind of
grab you and pull you into that world so
we'll see how it goes chill but gory as
hell yes
well phil thank you so much of course uh
for more on warhammer 40k dark tied make
sure to stay tuned to gamespot as well
as all our
as well as all of our other coverage
from summer game fest there was a noise
outside i was distracted
uh
make sure to subscribe to youtube.com
gamespot and we'll see you next time